okay it's time for hatred mail if you
have never heard hatred mail before I
get a lot of hate mail some of that hate
mail is almost poetic in nature in some
way shape or form takes a little bit of
imagination I understand and we take
that hate mail and a professional
voice-over artist narrates it for us
here's a quick reminder about hatred
mail we're so all right it's wrong
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom okay this week's hatred
mail the entire thing is what I call a
mute point not a moot point
it's a mute point take a listen to this
hashtag fake news Pakman is lying and
distorting the facts this is a mute
point already settled by legal experts
now it's just getting Pakman stupid the
Russian dossier is not illegal Hitler II
paid a former British agent who paid
Russians for info and got cheated by
being fed bogus unfitted crap and return
Hilary asked for the info and paid for
it first because if Trump proves false
it could hurt trust in Hillary's
campaign but it's still no illegal it
was unsolicited just yeah like many
hatred mails you know sometimes there
are lots of specific reactions that I
have I could address the use of the word
Hitler II that's when I've seen floating
around that's cute but honestly I think
my entire analysis would simply be mute
so I will only say that the best way to
send a middle finger salute to the hate
reott and say no no no you're wrong and
the left is right is to sign up for a
membership using the coupon code hey
tree at 40 that saves you 40 percent off
of your membership and the hatreds just
cry they immediately start bawling when
people use that coupon code because it
shows them that they are failing they
are failing to take down the David
Pakman show